The search has begun for volunteers for a mission to fly to Mars.
The only slight catch is that if you go, you can't come back.
It's part of a plan by a not-for-profit Dutch company called Mars One...
...who wants to establish a permanent human colony on the Red Planet.
Today, the Mars One foundation starts to search for Mars inhabitants,...
...the search for people from all nations who want to settle on Mars.
Mars One is a not-for-profit organization.
It is working on landing the first crew on Mars in 2023...
...and another crew every two years after that.
Takeoff, landing, and various parts of the mission will be streamed on the Internet...
...with Mars One claiming an estimated potential audience of four billion.
Successful applicants will have to undergo seven years training before the flight...
...which will take seven months.
The one-way nature of the mission has raised questions from some...
...over whether or not it's ethical.
Any big step that you take will always mean that there is risk.
Space missions always include risk and this mission will not be different.
When you send humans to Mars, there will be risks.
But we will select the people and we will tell those people the risks.
They will understand the risks and they will have to weigh the risks.
Do I want to take these risks to make my dream come true or do I not?
And it's up to the people who are going to determine if it's worth it for them.